quando nós estamos sofrendo e vamos ao
médico o que nós vamos buscar o que nós
esperamos encontrar quando nós estamos
incapacitados ou sentindo dor
quando nós estamos deprimidos anciosos e
com medo e não conseguimos dormir e
quando as pessoas que nós amamos e que
se preocupam conosco estão sofrendo
diante do nosso sofrimento e assim
frágeis vulneráveis e necessitados com
mágicas idealizados e perigosas e podem
se tornar as nossas expectativas diante
de uma consulta médica da pressão do
exame
o da receita de um medicamento e nós
como médicos e profissionais da área da
saúde em geral a indústria farmacêutica
os hospitais laboratórios e clínicas
como nós recebemos o nosso paciente com
a sua dor com as suas particularidades e
com as suas expectativas
desde os primórdios tendo como médicos
como quanto pacientes
nós tentamos através da resposta a essas
perguntas buscar e encontrar alívio para
o nosso sofrimento cura para a nossa
doença mas acima de tudo esperança
a medicina surgiu da simpatia por mal do
homem pelo humano
a base da medicina é a simpatia eo
desejo de ajudar outros e tudo que é
feito nesse sentido deve ser considerado
medicina
dizem muitas pessoas
o pai da medicina hipócrates disse
é mais importante conhecer o doente do
que a doença que ele sofre ao longo do
curso do tempo
quanto mais avançamos tecnológicamente
nas celas dos medicamentos dos exames
das técnicas cirúrgicas e agora mais
recentemente na área da genética -
humana e mais tecnicista tem se tornado
medicina
na visão de muitas pessoas a depressão
hoje é a segunda doença mais comum no
mundo e se tornará a primeira em 2025 é
a segunda causa de faltas ao trabalho do
mundo ea primeira causa no brasil também
conhecida como a doença da alma
a depressão é uma doença complexa sempre
causada por uma combinação muito
particular de fatores que inclui
predisposição genética características
da nossa personalidade desequilíbrio
químico cerebral estressores ambientais
entre outros
a depressão sempre será a única em cada
um de nós
ela pode causar desânimo tristeza apatia
perda de interesse
a alteração do sono apetite ansiedade
elevada e irritabilidade pessimismo
negativismo perda do sentido pela vida e
pode até levar ao suicídio
o tratamento da depressão é sempre um
grande desafio e muito complexo e os
tratamentos mais eficazes em geral são
chamados tratamentos combinados
psicoterapias um bom acolhimento
intervenções comportamentais e
ambientais e familiares e medicamentos
em um ato de medicar a depressão
atualmente vem sendo feito pelo método
o método de tentativa e erro que nos
concede como médicos em torno de 50% de
chance de acertarmos uma primeira
tentativa e pode tomar semanas muitos
meses
a medicina personalizada é a combinação
das boas práticas da medicina
tradicional e no caso da educação da
psiquiatria
o exame do estado mental do paciente
a análise das suas características de
personalidade da fase da vida em que ele
se encontra no nível de estresse aos ao
qual ele está submetido naquele momento
a nós seus exames laboratoriais seus
exames de neuroimagem e do resultado de
um teste forma com genético
a medicina personalizada permite
portanto nos distinguir enquanto
pacientes estabelecer tratamentos
customizados para cada um de nós
o seqüenciamento do genoma humano gerou
inúmeros avanços em várias áreas da
medicina entre eles a aceleração da
farmacogenética uma área que se ocupa e
estudar de que maneira o nosso dna
interfere no funcionamento e no
comportamento dos medicamentos no nosso
organismo o que a medicina personalizada
para depressão põe na mesa do médico e
do paciente é o texto fala uma coisa
genético é uma ferramenta que substitui
o método de tentativa e erro na escolha
dos medicamentos e torna os tratamentos
mais rápidos seguros eficazes além de
diminuir os seus custos como por exemplo
no caso de um de um homem que eu atendo
de aproximadamente 40 anos
aterrorizado pela perda da sua
capacidade de trabalhar e tocar o seu
negócio oficina mecânica e portanto de
sustentar sua família e da frustração
devido a inúmeros tratamentos mal
sucedidos e que tem a sua vida
recuperada a partir do tratamento que
foi reestruturado com a chegada do
resultado de um teste
o genético que demonstrou que ele ao
longo de todos esses anos por uma
infeliz coincidência vinha tomando
medicamentos que apresentavam baixa
resposta devido à presença de algumas
variantes genéticas no dna dele ou de
uma garota que ao tomar pela primeira
vez na vida um antidepressivo é
acometida de um fortíssimo episódio de
tontura que a levou a ficar acamada e
tomar uma conta de um segundo
antidepressivo que substituiu substituir
o primeiro igualmente ficou acamada a
comentar acometida por uma violenta
tontura e que depois que viu o resultado
do seu teste forma genético que
demonstrava que aquele medicamento que
ela tomou uma gota devido uma variante
genética que fazia com que ele fizesse
uma dosagem sanguínea abaixo do normal
sequer havia chegado perto de um
neurônio dela que fosse tranquilizou
então vou tomar o mesmo medicamento e
depois de algumas semanas se recuperou e
segue estável nos últimos três anos a
medicina do futuro chegou à inovação
tecnológica está ao nosso alcance
através da forma como genética de
inúmeras outras tecnologias incríveis
que até pouco tempo atrás os pareceriam
saídas de um filme de ficção científica
aprendemos a isso mas a nossa saúde no
futuro no presente ou em qualquer tempo
para ser alcançada em todo o seu
esplendor a sua maravilha ea sua beleza
precisou precisa e sempre precisará do
calor e do aconchego do humano
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]